right thank you good morning everybody
hold on sorry i'll give you a heads up
okay good to go
thank you very much good morning
everybody welcome to the risk and
assurance committee meeting on the 24th
of august
i think you've been here early and
obviously in extenuating circumstances
of uh lockdown four
we're doing it by way of zoom
having spent six hours
continuous on a meeting yesterday um i
think we need to be slightly forgiving
of each other
if we fail too but do try and remember
to unmute yourself
when you want to speak uh because i do
want to encourage you to have your voice
heard over the matters that we've got in
front of us this morning
um
uh uh we're obviously just a few minutes
late so apologies for that but as far as
i can work out we have a quorum
um but just a couple of apologies um
alex i think is a pretty definite
apology
darren i don't know whether you've
joined us yet but uh we haven't seen
darren so perhaps i could suggest we
accept an apology from darren for at
least lateness
oh no i'm absolutely here bruce
aaron you snuck in there at the end well
done mate so i'm here
as well
alex you're there as well oh brilliant
okay
so there are no apologies um but what i
would just not have had a couple of
indications
um leslie you need to shoot through it
10 30 correct
yes
you've got a commitment 11 for a period
of time uh albeit we might be getting
somewhere near the end by that point
so if we could just um
note those i will leave it at that i've
had no
indication of any public forum
you will have noted
on your
diligent boards
that there was
the addition in the last 24 hours of a
late major item
which relates to
the terms of reference of the
independent review of electronic access
this relates clearly as we all well know
to the events of the last fortnight
and
the value for us all to have a
review of arrangements
the document did take a bit of work to
produce
so it has come to us late
um but i would ask uh you'll leave that
we include that
on the basis that it's important that we
progress the matters that the terms of
reference
include
so look um i will firstly move from the
chair that the major late item terms of
reference independent review and
electronic access be accepted do i have
a second to please you'll need to say
your name
thank you darren
um uh yeah thank you ross i'll take
darren he was in first first hand i saw
um
so look the motion is here is there any
discussion
there being none i'll put the uh the
motion uh that we include this
uh all those in favor please say i
i
i was against
it's carried hey can i encourage you
please in from experience yesterday um
um if you want to vote for something or
indeed vote against it can you please
make certain your voice is heard uh
otherwise uh you and i have done this
one i think leslie and i'm pretty
certain everybody else is probably
voting eyes so
please have a good voice
uh there are no other changes to the
agenda um that i'm aware of that we have
when it comes to public studio i've had
a couple of corrections as to the
reasons why we are in public uh public
excluded for a couple of matters and
i'll raise those when we get to that
item
or sorry the the motion uh not not in my
view large issues but it's worthwhile
just
making certain we've got that right
um we have in front of us uh
the full agenda are there any matters of
um
interest or declarations of interest
that people need to make
great to be none can we please then move
to the minutes of our last meeting on
the 21st of june
at 8 30 when we're all in uh one room
together
i'd like to move from the chair
um that we uh um receive and resolve
that the minutes of the risk insurance
committee be confirmed i have a second
to please
thank you thank you for that
right are there any matters of accuracy
or correction that people noted in these
minutes that we should be aware of
because i want to say it looked like the
meeting that i was in
um it was a very good making actually
so i appreciate that if there are no
matter slits uh moved to the motion that
we confirm these all those in favor
please say aye
all right
thank you those against
it's caring appreciate that
groovy
if we could then move on to the next
item please which is the project
management office status report
um and erin i see you're on the line i
think we go straight to you to introduce
and
give us a heads up please
thank you bruce
um so the first thing i just wanted to
do today is
advise you that tess brown will be
taking us through today's project
management office report
but this is going to be the last report
that tess will be taking us through at
risk assurance she has been acting in
the role of head of our project
management office here since the
end of last year
however we've now appointed a permanent
employee into that role which is lee
butcher
lee is on the line today so i just
wanted to take that opportunity to
introduce lee um he's got a bit of a
quite a mix of of background from both
the public and the private sector
including quite a bit of time at
christchurch city council and is already
known to some of our staff from those
days um so yeah just wanted to introduce
lee
morning everybody how are you
good thank you
great welcome welcome on board uh as you
say christchurch see your influence
around the place
i'm getting uh
welcome anyway it's nice to have you
here and um
look we wish you well it's a really
important area as you well know for any
council so i appreciate having you on
board thank you very much we look
forward to actually being able to meet
you in person as well i think as all
as all the elected members and
colleagues would as well
thanks aaron
thank you and um i'll now hand over to
tess to take us through the body of the
report
morning everybody
hi it is how are you
over here
good
okay um so in terms of the report in the
last reporting period we've been making
good progress on on a number of projects
um in terms of this morning bruce would
you like me to
touch on the projects that have been
identified as still rising to the top
from an escalation perspective yes
please that would be very helpful okay
so i'll start with um with the museum
and it continues to be shown as a
project an escalated project because of
the
um
work that we're currently doing in the
reimagining phase in terms of resolving
the scope and then understanding um
budget and and just acknowledging that
we've got a wide stakeholder group that
we're working with we are making very
good progress in the reimagining phase
and the team is established and is
working with the working well with the
museum governance group so whilst we're
showing it as as a as a red project we
are making
significant progress through this
reimagining phase
um in terms of the branch home project
um that has got some um scoping issues
from a cost perspective
um just the nature of the industry that
we're working in at the moment with cost
escalations having come through from
when the budgets were established
probably 18 months ago or two years ago
so we're currently in a review process
with that project from a cost
perspective and the pcg is meeting next
week to understand where the numbers are
sitting and what that means um from a
project perspective
and then three waters it's a program of
work that again continues to have
challenges simply because of the status
of the industry with the constrained
market that we've got in southland and
the amount of work that your regional
councils are wanting to complete as well
as um city council so we have kind of
the perfect storm in terms of
competition for resourcing um a number
of dependencies because of that
resourcing which is creating um which
has the potential to create some
delivery issues for us that we're
watching
closely
so those are the projects that are are
currently um flagged as you know as
projects that we're working on um in
terms of city center streets obviously
that's on hold just before the lockdown
we had mobilized on site on don street
and we were due to mobilize on esk
street but obviously that has gone on
hold until we understand when we start
to move out of the alert levels what
implication that has had as well from a
program perspective
thank you for that that's that's um uh
good to have those headlights um look
runny as chair sorry bruce can i just um
just make two two highlighted points
just out of what tess has said um one of
them just being about what tess spoke to
around the brink's home job
i just want to give everybody a piece of
early heads up just around that job
you'll see that we've bought it out as
an individual item within our project
reporting now
that's because we do have some concerns
around that project so we think it needs
its own particular attention the
concerns around the project are that um
as tess mentioned there's about eleven
and a half million dollars in the long
term plan for that project a mix of
council money and three waters stimulus
money
however the budget that was put together
for it um to be fair was probably a
reasonably basic budget at the time that
the long-term plan was put together and
so we're seeing really significant
changes to that original budget um both
from the perspective of it didn't
include things like internal time it
didn't include things like um
contingency it was based on a um a
standard i guess traditional method of
delivering the project via open
trenching um whereas we're going to have
to be doing a significant amount of
underground directional drilling on the
project and we've also had to take a
different route to the one imagined
that means that the cost of that project
is escalating to the point where we
haven't finalized the full budget for it
but we are expecting it to be in the
vicinity of 18 million or more up from
that 11 and a half million so that's a
significant jump on that project
so i just wanted to give everybody an
early awareness of that i don't we
haven't updated the full budget in the
reports yet because i didn't want to put
a figure in that we didn't have
confidence in yet
but we are working to to
close out what that full budget will be
for that project um at a more detailed
level
i do want to talk to one other thing but
just if there's any questions on that
look what i'd like to do is i'd be very
happy to hear your other point i'd then
like rung your chair infrastructure just
to whether there's any broad thing there
but i want to remind us we're a risk
committee
so i'm more interested in actually the
general the general and the high level
issues of actually how do we pursue our
capital program which is what i'd like
the committee to focus on so erin very
happy to hear your other point and
invite running to speak and then we'll
open it up
thank you the the other one was just as
tess alluded to we were meant to due to
start work on streetscapes this week
just want to make sure that everybody is
clear that you know we may have some
concerns around keeping to that very
ambitious program particularly through
to the may next year farmers opening
now obviously the icl building is is
also
not progressing at the moment
and once we do come down the alert
levels we'll as tess mentioned need to
work through how our two programs are
still meshing together but just wanted
to make sure that everybody was aware
that we were already running a tight
program around that one and the risk has
just increased now
does that interest you get back to work
what at level two or level three
it can be at level three but there's
obviously increased health and safety
requirements that have to be taken into
account right and we are just working
through that at the moment just around
the national guidance um as to whether
it needs to be a nationally significant
project or not to get to work under
level three
yeah
appreciate that
rangi is anything from your committee's
work today that would be relevant for
our broader consideration of risk
um i'm pleased to uh hear that variance
like i'm not pleased with the number but
i was that was one of my questions with
the rank term
pints
and i'll take this time to say that you
know this is the
this is the black art of three waters
that we have to work with and i've got
no idea how a new government entity
would come even close
to dealing with these variances
and be as nimble as a council can be
now the other thing i just want to make
sure of is with streetscapes
is that everything even though i'm on
the ccgg committee
that everything is in line between what
cityblock wants for their
tenancies that open out onto the street
and with our designers that everything
is in sync
and we're not going to find later down
the track that there may be there may be
issues or compromises especially since
we're starting with a fresh palette so
that's one of my concerns and i see that
at a risk at this stage until this
council can be satisfied
think of that ranging
the black art of three waters i agree
um folk can i open up the questions
please distress we're here about trying
to think about the total capex program
rather than
necessary discussion individual project
unless it's giving us a sense of those
high risks can i open it up for
discussion questions for
uh tess or aaron or indeed if that's the
feds wanted
yes alex
alex i think you're on mute um i can't
hear you sorry here we go is that better
brilliant can hear you well
um so i guess this question has probably
been asked previously but um
with the
straight both the streetscapes project
and cargo central limited with the
covered levels and obviously with the
work program being shifted back weeks
and weeks now
um and if we continue to move they have
to shift the program
the
what are the penalties going to be
um or what have we what have we got um i
guess built into the contracts that
allows for a buffer or is there anything
that allows for a buffer of time there
that you know given if the projects are
continually shifted back are we going to
be able to meet that may deadline
so alex we were we were already working
to an incredibly tight program
um so
yeah so i think what we've got to do is
once we can get on site and we can
establish the programs that we're going
to be working to with the other
developments um then we'll be in a
position to regroup and and understand
what that means from a time and a and a
cost perspective but i imagine there's a
couple of there's probably three to four
weeks before we'll be in a position that
we'll be able to come back with anything
anything really solid and in terms of
being able to perform the group
and i suppose
just at a high level at this stage and i
can go into it more later on when we
deal with the report on icl um but
obviously uh we had plans in progress
last time around having already been
through this on the last occasion when
we're in the lockdown so we've pulled
out the program of work and the way that
we proposed to work under level three
and the last occasion which we had
approval for abl have already started
working with mb and all the other
associated entities to make sure they
get that into place and so we're doing
what we can at the moment but at this
stage obviously until we see the end of
it it's pretty hard to put a firm figure
on what if any impact it'll have
and similarly the streetscapes is
working with downers as well in terms of
putting plans in place to be able to
work under level three but it is just
that interface between the projects that
we need to resolve
and does the extension of time contracts
or the whole the whole issue of of um
rates under under um being prevented and
locked down for is that affecting is
that a potential again either andrew
ortiz was these contracts
contractors will be entitled to an
extension of time claim or a variation
under
it depends on the particular
construction contract and i mean i know
under our contract they will be entitled
to a variation because of the the delay
that they've incurred
and similar for us and obviously their
contracts got a bit smarter i don't know
testers might be a little bit more over
this than ours were but obviously has
been a pre-covered contract
and really was sort of there but very
poorly worded at this stage i suppose
we've managed to work with abl to really
avoid any of those issues up to date um
you are now getting closer to crunch
time when it might start to have real
impacts and so we'll have to see how
that plays out but to date we haven't
had to go down the contractual argument
path
um and we'll hope to avoid that if we
can but obviously it depends on where we
end up
great
questions from members
no
um so look just
to recap in
tess
and aaron there's probably there's
probably four biggies that sit on my
mind here one is
we've just been discussing the alignment
of projects generally under a very tight
time constraint as an issue
that's also closely related to to covert
being an issue
the other thing that i've heard aaron
and yes is particularly around the
brink's home
water main and rangi's reference to
black hearts
we might give him a minute to reconnect
yes whilst we are waiting for that were
there any other questions
your worship
oops
can you hear me all right we can
oh very good
um
i wanted to speak to item seven
um
the
we had a bit of an accident with the um
equipment here
we're not on that diet to meet your
worship
oh god
but it's it's still still to come
my apologies i think i dipped out there
did folk lose me because i lost you folk
sorry about that
i'm in the uh the depths as as i had to
get geographically corrected by um
uh clearly yesterday uh western
southland and the connection may not be
the best at all i wanted
so my apologies for that
your camera is freezing quite often
oh is it idea i'm afraid to say
um as i've been living area without
broadband so i'm dealing off mobile um
so uh believe you may
choose through it for a bit
hopefully um look if it gets worse can
you just tell me please and it might be
that we've got to find some alternate
arrangement
um
in the middle of the summary
wait a sec sorry uh so a suggestion from
darren which is good thing yep
uh to uh listen the impact on your
broadband you can actually turn your
camera off so that'll reduce the chance
of your audio buffering
people are happy not to see my face
which is quite okay
uh i'll do that how's that
right here we'll try that word comes the
worst you need to see my face give me a
yell thank you for that uh advice darren
so look if i just go back to it i was
trying to think of those those
those
higher issues
alignment covered
stimulus with our problems with our
budgets
and obviously i'm noting that with the
reimagining of the museum with the
rework around the brext home it must
raise an issue that that our funding
approach
is changing
so i just want um there may be other
risks but they seem to be the biggie
biggies and aaron the other thing sorry
that i've just noted from you is the
uh um the impact of the
the general contracting market
can i ask at that higher level are there
any strategies
other than staying close to your
contractors that we've heard about that
you are thinking
about implementing or considering at the
stage
yes so happy to talk through that um one
of the things that we we have
established is there there are some
panels in place to help us with our
professional services around project
management quantity surveying things
like that in terms of the contracting
market we did some work when we were
first setting up the project management
office around whether or not we should
be establishing a panel of contractors
to undertake this work on our behalf we
have done that around our three waters
panel and that's a joint panel with
southland district council
but across our broader projects uh we to
be honest they were so varied that we
didn't see that we you know the benefits
of being able to establish a panel of
that type if we'd have had a very large
roading program or three waters program
um or all of our projects were quite
similar property ones we might have gone
down that path but because everything
was so varied we we haven't um used that
as an option
to your point though we are working
closely with the market around who's
available making sure that they're aware
of the timings that the projects are
coming to market and trying to generate
as much interest in those as possible
the other thing that we've done is have
a piece of work undertaken
just around the the market in the lower
south island and what other projects are
happening over the next five years and
how our program links in
with that work um so that we can see
where there's gaps peaks and troughs um
and also
where those particular constraints in
the market will be
and also those
i guess
projects that allow us to potentially
leverage off uh players that will have
come down to the lower south island in
the market to do other work
that may be of assistance in terms of
timing our projects to you know fit in
behind or before those projects
thank you
from a funding side michael um i'm not
saying any of these increased potential
increases uh are actually um mandated um
but our financial strategy it's impact
yeah i just wanna to remind councillors
at this point that it is a full
programme funding approach that we've
taken
and just just to
bear in mind that we were pressed in
relation to being able to deliver the
full program as it stood which was
highlighted by the uh external auditors
at the time
uh this actually points towards in favor
of uh
that that view and that
we'll be watching that on a quarterly
basis from a finance sense at this point
i don't have any
major concerns in relation to that i
will continue to monitor that on a
quarterly basis so actually i'll be
monitoring it on a monthly basis but
i'll present accounts monocularly
but no concerns from my perspective at
the moment
thanks michael yes
so just moving forward with our ltp
uh quite a few years to a secondary
water supply
which is in the same sort of league with
three waters
the money we've got set aside for that
i mean obviously there's another ltp in
between that but
how far off the mark do we think we are
or is it
worth thinking about that now
we're constantly moving the numbers
counsellor
potentia
from that perspective and we'll have
that view in relation to
the next ltp to reforecast that
just also i'd probably remind council at
this point that we have an extra buffer
in relation to our policy around our
deck cap so that's something that may
come under question need to be reviewed
at the next ltp
particularly in mine with any changes
around what our our water site
brings us
thank you for that michael
um look i'm just conscious of both my
dipping out and back and we probably are
taking a lot of time over it's a very
key item are there any um really urgent
questions folk like to raise or could i
move to the resolution please
thank you for that aaron and tessa that
has been a very valuable um uh insight
and one which we will be we will
continue to model interest and obviously
we've got an item coming up which
is really is really important so
um can i move to the resolution please
which is simply that we
receive the report the project
management office status report i think
in the sake of um being
online i i will probably just move this
myself do i have a second to please
need to shout your name if you're going
to do it
yes
ross is there too nobby
i see you you're
the hand raised yeah um
bruce i am happy to have a second that i
i had the the hand up
uh as an electronic way just saying i
wanted to comment a little bit about the
topic that we just closed off that's all
all right well we'll we'll accept your
your second um so we're open for
discussion on the motion so can you go
ahead please snobby yeah just just one
one quick thing that rangy raised which
wasn't uh he suggested that
potential funding for branks homer if it
got over the well over the uh figures
that we're looking at could be the money
that we've got put aside for sydney
water supply just just from my under
award
a warning there if we leave the
secondary water supply
too long it will get under the water
entity and i don't think it will be a
priority for them to do it if we can do
it before we transfer across in 2024 or
have some traction in the secondary
water area
we're more likely to get it for city
than if we wait in a priority line
in the south island
i'm just running in there i can't see
the screen sorry look i didn't want to
drag money out of
frank's home oh sorry out of the
secondary water supply i just wanted to
make us aware that maybe the experience
could occur with that project
no way did i want to take any money out
of that
thank you
thank you both there any other points
people would like to make to the motion
there being none i'll um i'll put i've
moved the motion and i'll be second to
thank you nobby um that we resolve to
receive the project office status report
all those in favor please say aye
aye aye
it's carrie thank you very much
right we're moving to um a verbal item
which is the working on working together
and uh jeff could i invite you to give
us some words of wisdom please
jeff are you with us are you on mute
he does appear to be in the call but he
does appear to be on mute
i can pick it up cheer if you like
yeah like why don't you we'll start
anyway lindsey
actually i can't see um uh jeff on my
screen to be honest so i'm not sure what
the story is yeah he's there on another
maybe i'll apologize can you hear me now
there you go i can hear you here yes
yeah
apologies look um i'm like you bruce my
internet connection is not flash so i if
i if i freeze uh lindsay's going to
share the report anyway
just on the working on working together
a lot of this will now be based on the
next phase which will be subject to
look the thompson report and its
possible recommendations which the
council will have to give some
consideration to
we started the uh full working groups
back up local schedule for last week but
as you're all aware postponed because of
um
lockdown
but there has been some
quite a bit of work done uh in terms of
the working groups and some progress are
made around
uh aspects in terms of support to the to
the councillors so
first there's been good progress around
um the support functions on
the work that's being done on how
agendas are created
and support support staff towards the
council's
committees
and also work done on the news new
policy for members expenditure and
allowances
and the lagoma requests uh process has
now been developed
where they are tracked in a much better
way than was which was raised in the
original report
uh in regard to the auditor general
counsellor's professional development
workshops uh have been underway they are
still programmed right through to the
end of the year and can i just thank
councillors on the basis of their
feedback at each of those workshops
we're taking note
in consideration of some of the comments
in regard to timing etc
and
we appreciate that feedback but it makes
it easier for us to give
some pointers to future workshops
and presenters
there's a new template being developed
for reporting
uh for preparing staff from their advice
they give to councils and committees and
that you'll start to see that roll out
in september
uh in terms of
uh the future week there's the other one
that's in terms of the working groups
which i'll get lindsay to cover
is regard to the ltp process and comps
lindsey
yeah thanks jeff and chair i've got a
task of heading up the working group um
with the title of strategic projects
prioritization and i just want to give
you a brief heads up on how that's
tracking
you'll all know
that the ltp process was a pretty
successful one
contributed to by a significant
commitment not only by yourselves but
also by
the team within the organization
and to some extent that work is
overtaken
the working groups um
task
that said um the working groups agreed
that there would be value in
capturing
uh collating pulling out of you like
the icc's ltp process and embedding it
in
uh your systems and processes for future
application
so to that end an external resource has
been engaged simon markham
to take a bit of pressure off rhiannon
and collate uh all of the good things
that have happened uh during the last
cycle
he's running a best practice lens over
it and our expectation is that the
outcome of that will go back to the
working group in fact it was on the
agenda
for the council uh the cancelled working
group meeting and ultimately it will
find its way through with the
outcome of the survey
and the workshop for councillors
reflecting on the ltp process to this
committee and and then to council
probably won't close out that working uh
group's
task in september areas hopes probably
pushed out to october now i would say
cheers
now just on comms um remains the
challenging area of course
uh council adopted a framework for its
communications in maine it's great now
that we've got a strategic comms manager
on on task in the in the form of police
and night
and her appointment has seen a bit of a
lift in
um
and comms across the organisation
including um an increase in the regular
um media briefings on relevant topics so
that's a wrap i think on what the eas
are up to chair
thank you
thank you lindsay that's that's um
that's really helpful um are there any
questions or points that uh
members would like to make at the stage
please
um are we up to item seven years
not quite uh uh sir tim we're still
dealing um with working on working
together so item seven is the next one
i'll let you know
you've got your chance to say
any other items in relationship to the
verbal report from the eas
so obviously the the critical thing is
as you have hinted at jeff is the uh the
need for
uh richard's report to be finalized and
be brought to the committee um uh
um i had uh um
obviously been keen that we get that our
way soon
uh our problem being of course locked
down and for a report which um
uh is substantive for us it's a critical
six-month review
i was keen that we
hold out if it's the right word to be
able to meet in person to deal with that
and that was the nature of the short
brief i put out at the end of last week
and
of course last night we've seen the
extension of level four until at least
the end of this week
so
i i
will discuss this with claire and try
and work out what is the best way to
bring it maybe that we have to deal with
this one by way or zoom or
electronically which i think is less
desirable mainly because it is obviously
a really critical point to be able to
discuss
but at this stage
all i can say is that
it's progressed well um but we need to
find a way to bring it
to us we may have to seek your leave to
build electronically which as i've said
from my perspective is less desirable
than meeting in person
right with that i just wonder if we
don't have a formal motion but i think
it's important please that from the
chair i will move
that we receive the verbal update of the
the two ea's could i have a second to
please
thank you darren appreciate that
um any discussion on the motion
there being none i'll put it all those
in favor please say aye
aye
those against it's caring thank you
right we will move to item seven and the
term i'll certainly let you have a
chance to have a say but first firstly
um i'd like to i'd like to invite um
issues jane is it you that are that are
introducing this um or clear to speak
first before i open it up to um
uh to start to sorry to members
um
i'm happy to bruce with cleveland thank
you jane appreciate it whatever yeah
morning everybody it's a nice sunny day
in christchurch and i think you've got
good weather down there too
um
if i can just talk
these are
a brief covering report and a two-page
terms of reference if i can talk just
briefly to the covering report
and draw your attention to maybe three
paragraphs
under the background and context
firstly way back in your meeting on 27th
of april
you passed a resolution that the chief
executive take the necessary steps to
support the deputy mayor in supporting
the mayor and representing the city
and that talked about
at the meeting we talked a lot about the
need to utilize electronic access to the
mayor's icc email account way back then
and then if we fast forward a couple of
paragraphs down to the 17th of august
just recently we got a
media query from the odt
about the subject of access to the
mayor's emails
and how the chief executive had
knowledge of a statement the previous
week
now um
claire put out a media statement and we
could consider that that was the matter
was dealt with
but we felt that it seems that there's a
range of understanding and appreciation
of how council correspondence is treated
and therefore thought we needed
independent
confirmation of what we're doing
so that's a thumbnail of the the
background
um before we get to the terms of
reference if i could just draw your
attention to
our recommendation that we appoint
robert buchanan to do this work
there's a paragraph in the covering
report about
robert's
expertise in the area and i think most
of you will know him as he's done work
for council before
um importantly robert's able to start um
immediately
and have something to us
by mid-september if council wished to
[Music]
asset resolution
so maybe
shall i just keep going go through the
terms of reference then take questions
bruce or do you want to post i think
that would be that would be useful
please we took it that way jane okay
um so on to the terms of reference
themselves
look the the background and contract
context is just a
longer version of what's in the covering
report so i won't go through that but i
will
draw your attention to the brief which
is the heart of
what we're suggesting needs to be done
um
we
we talk about reviewing the arrangements
for electronic communications
which um where
excuse me um which go back to the
discussion on april 27th
the the key bits i guess are the seven
bullet points
the first three are the the sort of
big picture things
so going to
going to the policy
um
and
reviewing the policy itself it's called
electronic access
and use policy for staff and for
non-staff
then it's important to look at how that
relates
to the
ligoima
stuff and the privacy act requirements
but the third thing is equally important
just making sure that everybody
who
needs to
has the same understanding of the
systems and processes in place to do
this stuff
so that's the the big picture stuff
then we go
and
focus
the review
into supporting the mayor through his
icc email account
um so that takes us back to the
deliberations that were um held last
april
um
the discussions that were held in the
resolution that's on the books
and then um
that
we move on to looking at the special
arrangements which were subsequently put
in place and again relating them back to
our other statutory
function requirements
then looking at what we actually do
and
comparing that and contrasting it with
practice and other mayoral offices
and then finally focusing on the email
of the 10th of
august
so i
i think that's all i need to say there's
there's three recommendations there
that we're suggesting
that this committee
might like to adopt and put to council
but there is an opportunity to have a
discussion and make any improvements or
amendments that they wish to make to the
terms of reference
i hope that's um i hope that's given
folk admittedly this is a major late
item so look i'd like to
i'd like to suggest that we undertake
this
uh conversation with a couple of things
in mind this is about whether we
undertake a review to clarify an issue
it's not to litigate the issue now
um we've all spoken not week but there
has been a number
discussions about this in the media
and that is where that lies
this is about whether the clarity of a
review would help us
and obviously the strong recommendation
of the
staff paper is that it would so this is
a debate about do we undertake a review
or not
and if we do
are the terms of reference reasonable
that we will support
um so firstly given it's a major light
item
i'd like to raise or ask members do they
want to raise issues particularly around
the terms of reference
and then i will open up for more general
discussion about whether or not we
undertake the review
so the questions about the the terms of
reference at this stage
yes well i'd like to um speak to that
are we finally at item seven now
we are indeed saturn
okay
um
yes
i know that it's um the meeting of uh
august
17th is where we got to last time but
uh
and
i think it
does try and set out responsibilities
and clear up lines of communication but
it doesn't give
anyone the right to
hack my emails
and
i think it's
an improper act and a misuse of
email
to go down that road
neither claire or her advisors
should play any role in choosing
who conducts the review
clear is implicated as a party to the
alleged improper use
of an email
and the report downplays the [ __ ]
lack of content
by me
as to hacking
the emails and the report does not make
any distinction between
interception and misuse
misuse being a serious
offence
so tim can i just jump in there please
i appreciate i appreciate the the
sensitivity of this
[Music]
we have a terms of reference
which is seeking clarity on what is our
policy around electronic access
we are seeking to understand whether
were the basis for support
of yourself and others
and also
the support which is not uncommon for
meres
of
managing the email account
is reasonable
i think it's a big
difference between that and what you're
alluding to and i would want to caution
you
about using words like hacking
we're talking about something which is
about here for support
and whether that has been done
reasonably
uh or not
darren i saw your hand up would you like
to make a point please
uh thanks first look the point i was
going to make you've just touched on
it's not hacking
it's not hacking when people have
legitimate legal access it's in the
policy uh hacking implies something
illegal which this wasn't so i just
wanted to point out it's not an
appropriate term
thank you darren hence enhanced my
understanding of the terms of reference
they are around a review of the actual
arrangements
that were intended
uh and what was actually put in place
yeah bruce
yeah sure nobody
um just a couple of things on the things
mentioned by the mayor and and
subsequently by darren
um just to counsel that it's really a
bit unwise for us to be stating our
position on this i mean i've got a view
that's very similar to darren's
but it's important that we allow this
process if we go through this to take
its course and to not prejudge uh there
are opposing views on both sides of this
debate and i've been in the middle of
that
um and i just think that there is
neutrality in this paper coming forward
it's forwarded by jane who's done a lot
of independent work for for working uh
on working together and i don't see any
uh suggestion that clears over the top
of this in fact she hasn't commented on
this matter which is great
and i i'm certainly in favor of the
terms of reference and certainly in
favor of the recommended uh reviewer as
well thank you
thank you navi are there any other
comments people would like to make
well i think it would be foolish for
this council to expose clear to
criticism
by not treating uh
her office or herself as as an affected
party
um
being involved
by being involved in the choice of who
the review person is
she exposes her office to accusations of
lack of impartiality
uh so tim can i just remind you what
nobby um has just said um the pen
on this review has been held by
uh jane in her semi-independent view
i have also as the chair of risk and
assurance
being consulted over it
and indeed was approached as to who
might be appropriate to be the reviewer
um we are all in some way affected by
this uh this review
but the essence here is that um uh jane
has bought a paper with recommendations
for us as a committee to recommend to
full council
that they adopt
so it's it is a council review
that is being suggested here not
claire's review
bruce
yes
just as a follow-on to what the mayor
said about uh claire and her team
potentially um
steering us in a direction that that
would suit her um that that's not been
my experience as you will all be aware i
had a code of conduct last year that
involved
robert buchanan being the independent
reviewer and while the review didn't go
in my favor i found him to be extremely
professional and open to a wide range of
discussions about uh what it transpired
so i think he's an ideal person for it
thank you
if you don't like the word hacking and
that's really comes through media
what would you suggest is an alternative
terminology
so tim we have used we have used if we
go to the terms of reference
the the
approach that was anticipated in the
policy and
what i think it's fair to say jane was
anticipated through the april meeting
which was electronic access in support
to your email account
that's quite different to the use of the
word hacking
that's right and i i was at that april
meeting as everybody else was and
remember the discussion
i think tonight access
brief
yes
just to allow the mayor's fears about um
this being a little bit of a setup i
guess
um
certainly i would expect and i think
everybody else would that robert when he
does his review if he's the person that
we approve will come down and interview
the mayor
he'll interview
claire myself um other members of the
cheers group that were at the meeting so
there's plenty of opportunity to have
have you say and use words like hacking
that's the way you feel but i think we
should just step back a little bit
and approve the terms of reference and
uh decide whether you want robert or
somebody else
thanks navi appreciate that
well i know
dan's
noted in the minutes
and
sorry tim what was it you wanted noted
in the minutes
um my
opposition to
the resolution and the recommendations
thank you um we'll get to that point
when we when we look at the resolutions
any other comments folk would like to
make at this point
yeah i would bruce coming back again i'm
sorry for hogging space
um i'd like to hear from the mayor why
he's opposed to this resolution which
really brings somebody independent in to
have a look at it he's made some media
statements that he feels
i guess quite violated by the intrusion
of people into his email system and i
think it's only proper for us as a
council to get some independent review
of that that we don't deal with
internally because that just creates
more issues for us
um and i'd like to know why the mayor
feels that he's in opposition to an
independent person coming in who is of
good standing and will take some time to
review all the issues involved including
the issues that the mayor may have
well it
doesn't deal with the
issues that i felt felt and
the um
having someone
review your
operation
is um
it's
i don't think the perception will be
that this is really
clean
slate operation
so with respect to your worship
um i heard jane read out the terms of
reference and the first one for me was
the most important one
it talked about um
giving consideration to leguma and the
privacy act which is what i guess is the
backstop for you to say i feel as though
my personal emails should not be
subject to review by anybody internally
um
and you're quite right to have that
position if that's what you want so i
think that's one of the terms of
reference that the review will actually
focus in on and that's your opportunity
to say what you need to say
i think it's i think the approach as uh
you've outlined knobby is is um is both
at the general or rather jane did which
makes sense in terms of why we have
electronic access or other what is the
rules around it and then how we
implemented it through it
i've got rangi and then i think i've
seen lindsay's hand so rangi you're
first and then leslie
well since we're engaging in a review
should we include the allegations of
bullying which
have been done in the media and that's a
very strong allegation towards council
members which i've taken offense to
but i was quite um
okay to let that rest but is this
something that the independent would
reviewer would look into
if he is going to be looking into that
incident
jahin would you have a comment on that
um i i
i think that's a completely different
issue
and
just taking you back to the the points
that
bruce highlighted
this is a high-level review not a review
of one incident
um it looks at the big picture it it
looks at whether we have done what we
said we would do properly and we all
understand
how the systems and processes work
the the any allegations of
bullying are
nothing to do with this
in my view
thank you so
so just following on would a um
a counselor then do that under his own
bat if he had an issue with that
there are always options for
councillors um
but i think that's relevant to this
point as james said
lindsay have you got a point to make or
a question please well thanks chair it's
an observation from somebody who has
been
on both sides of this debate in previous
lives and i and i want to make those
observations about the terms of
reference
in my view they're solid and they're
principled and they're supported by an
independent person of
of standing within the sector
they look at both policy and practice
and the application of the policy and
the practice
i think they'll serve the council's
interest particularly well and i can't
fault them and i commend the um adoption
by the committee
thank you lindsay
leslie
thank you bruce
lindsay's actually said a great deal of
what i was going to say i think that
they are
high level and very solid and well put
together recommendations
and my comment on the suggested
independent reviewer is that
is that
robert buchanan has impeccable
um references for the job
we would be hard put to find someone
of his qualifications and independence
if we were looking for other names i'm
i'm very comfortable i think they're
neutral it's a neutral um
and well put together
um
suggested review
and
there could be no one better than robert
to be an independent
reviewer whom we can definitely accept
would give everybody a very fair hearing
and write an extremely carefully um put
together report
thanks bruce
thank you leslie appreciate your support
it feels like
unless there are any questions of
clarifications points to make that's
relevant that we move to the resolution
so
i have one
yes sure
um just just to comment on what rangi
writes about the issue of uh claims in
the media by the mayor of bullying i
guess the way to activate that is not
through this
terms of reference but i guess both the
mayor and any
on the flip side any council that felt
agreed by those statements could
activate a code of conduct which could
then dovetail with
buchanan's visit so i guess that's an
avenue that's open to members if they
feel that the mayor's uh comments were
unwarranted or open to the mayor himself
if he felt he was being bullied
i think their points were made i'd just
like to keep this clear that we're
dealing here with um this terms of
reference rather than
than making it broader i think we've had
um and we will test for the resolution
the level of support about the um the
clarity of the terms of reference and
its need
could i move to the result the
resolutions please which are
obviously
that we receive
uh the report which is the cover report
thank you jay
and importantly we recommend to council
that the terms of reference uh be
adopted
i think we can remove um
with any amendments because nobody is
proposing an amendment
that robert
buchanan as we've discussed to be
appointed to undertake the review
we know by the way that you can start
basically straight away which is useful
and that and that we note the estimated
cost is up to ten thousand dollars plus
gst
and that can be accommodated within
existing budgets
is there any um so look from the chair i
will move this motion do i have a second
one yeah i'm happy to do that
thank you nobby i had a few hands here
thank you but i heard your voice first
knobby appreciate that
um so let's see any discussion on the
motions
i was just going to say i've had my say
thank you very much and um well we'll
check when we get to the voting but i
think you have had a request i think
you're going to request that your name
be
recorded in this vote can i please put
all formations as one set
all those in favor please say i
i i i
those against
hi
thank you sir tim i just want to confirm
your your
vote is against the resolution
and if if your statements are correct
from earlier in discussion you would
like your name recorded in the minutes
as having voted against this motion
correct
correct
thank you very much
we'll make that happen
okay thank you for that appreciate
appreciate that discussion it's an
important one and one which i think will
help us in the long run as we get
through things
can i move then to uh
um to the procurement policy please
under item eight
uh michael that's under your name but um
maybe there are other people to speak on
this who perhaps i don't know
yes thank you cheer um i'd like to
introduce um nick bridges is the
procurement manager um new to
icc so he'll be presenting this report
and rhiannon sutra or we who we all know
um just because it's about consultation
and engagement as well so i'll hand over
to those two
thank you nick and ryan and i'll uh
we're in your lead or your hands
whichever way is most useful please
good morning uh my name's nick bruce
this is michael stage i've been here
about nine weeks now
the uh concept behind the procurement
policy and the procurement manual
basically is to codify
some of the good practices that already
exist within council like in
infrastructure but to also have a
cohesive approach going forward and
perhaps most importantly making the
market very clearly aware
of what
our project will be in terms of
procurement and internet website on
procurement
which is under development
i don't know if there's any specific
questions
i keep cutting out you do
yes i don't think can i i'll time my
video off
it'd be a good idea nick would you like
me to say that again
yes please that would just just the the
the
help right um
the aim of the procurement manual and
policy is to basically codify some very
good practices that currently exist in
council e.k infrastructure
and also to
bring align all the other activities
under one procurement policy and manual
going forward
we are also looking to have an intranet
and internet website on procurement
which is currently under development
i can answer any specific questions
brilliant so if i can just um just check
for the benefit of the committee this
isn't as you say an attempt to codify so
we are trying through this policy
to
bring our approach
together uh nick i can't help but also i
think this does relate back to the
previous discussion we had on capital
expenditure and enabling
aaron tessa and koda have the relevant
flexibility to meet today's markets
conditions
as well
can i
invite
any comment folk would like to make
including erin and michael i
think you have been probably involved
and this is of interest to you michael
yes thank you chair um i'd just like to
get rhiannon to mention
um about the consultation engagement
plans
because when
this is a draft um that we're putting
forward today because we still need to
go through our engagement
internally and externally so just if i
can hand over to rand just to discuss
those matters
thanks michael um
killer councillors um yes so
really the key point is that as nick
says a lot of this procurement policy is
about codifying um existing and best
practice so that the market is really
clear on how council procures and that
supports the capital program um it also
includes an option to allow for social
procurement so
many of you will be aware of
social procurement and increasing
interest in the community around how
council as a significant purchaser of
services might support the four
well-beings
this is um a complex topic both from a
political perspective and then then from
an administrative perspective and so
hence the proposed engagement plan which
suggests
holding a workshop with councillors
ahead of bringing the policy back
to risk and assurance before
consultation
to give you the opportunity to discuss
how
the four well-beings interact together
when it comes to procurement
council is obviously doing many million
dollars of business and delivery of the
capital works program is core to um the
procurement policy
and it's really important that all of
those factors of well-being are
considered and that you counselors have
the opportunity to give some guidance as
to where you want that issue to sit
thank you rhiannon michael was anything
else you need to add
no i just wanted to support that viewer
around the social procurement that is
new from our policy perspective and it
is something that will need further
discussion as part of those workshop and
consultation processes
open to questions
oh thank you and i just wanted to check
with aaron um as i said to me this does
have some relationship back to the
capital procurement program this is
driving in the right direction for you
and the challenges that you and your
team face
thank you chair um look yes we've um
well i've reviewed the draft procurement
policy
i think that it still allows us quite a
bit of flexibility in terms of
being sensible in the way that we
procure things and providing the ability
to i guess have a standardized codified
way of doing things as per the norm um
but also to deviate from that from time
to time um through a particular
approval process to allow us to
uh to your point respond to particular
market conditions
the i just want to make a comment around
what both michael and rhiannon have said
around
social procurement um and also around
buying local and the fact that we need
to work through how we apply those
particular pieces and make sure that
we're still able to
um
i guess get get large chunks of work out
to the market in a quick manner
as opposed to breaking them down into
too many too many smaller chunks which i
guess is a little bit more beneficial
from the the local market and social
procurement perspective so we'll be
working through in the next stages of
this process and and to rhiannon's point
where we're wanting to involve elected
members in that discussion on just
making sure that we get the balance
right between those social procurement
local market
value for money
and ability to deliver elements
but definitely happy with the direction
of it
thank you so that's that's really
important so i draw members attentions
into the
proposed
engagement process which clearly also
involves
so essentially involves the development
or affirmation of the approach and how
do we find that balance
and that's i think that's on page 25 of
my diligent book
bottom of the page there is a whole
engagement process leading to the policy
develop policy being brought back to the
committee on the 8th of december
is there any questions or discussions
folk would like to make at this point
just to one point bruce
yes surely nobody um on page 18 and it
might not be the appropriate page
anymore it talks about um variations or
over a hundred thousand dollars
it's a there's not a paragraph i just
read out to you
it starts off with the weightings will
be
not the same for each uh procurement
and so where it's over a hundred
thousand um a procurement plan must be
developed by the business and approved
by procurement
and i don't see any link between that
and what goes forward which is where
general managers can generally approve
a range of things which is in the policy
document going out for submission
i just wonder what that approved by
procurement means or within that sort of
variation or that waiting that puts into
a tender
needs to be approved by general manager
yes
the idea of procurement's involvement
normally is to ensure the plan is
reasonably comprehensive and relevant to
the
size of the transaction or the risk
being
taken
during the procurement process
we don't
normally stop what we normally do is
just add or ask questions if we think
something's missing or hasn't been
considered
so the approval basically is to make
sure there is a plan
and to raise any issues that we're
concerned about before we go to market
yeah thanks that nick and just maybe a
slight wording so that when we go out
people are aware what it means it may
need to be approved by the procurement
manager
okay thank you
are there any other comments people
would like to make at the stage
right i wonder if we could move then to
the um
uh
the resolutions please which is firstly
that we received the report of um
uh nick and rhiannon
and secondly we note the proposed
engagement approach
and that the
the consortium on draft policy will be
brought back to us
uh for adoption ahead of sorry will be
brought back for adoption ahead of the
consultation to september to september
uh risk insurance risk is it september
or december sorry can i just check there
it's it's september is it
indeed it is mr robertson
yes it is i must have misread my uh my
timing okay so so i'll go back to it so
that the proposed engagement note that
the proposed engagement approach and the
draft policy will be brought back for
adoption head of consultation uh uh to
the next meeting in september
again for the sake of ease i will move
that motion do all motions do i have a
second to please
i'll second that
thank you i think it was ubex if i went
by the sound of the voice
i'll um
is there any discussion on the motion
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
aye
thank you those against
it's carried appreciate that
right
continuous
improvement peter
uh morning off i'll um take it as the
continuous improvement update has been
read
this was an update of improvements since
the
june risk and insurance committee
meeting
um happy to take any questions regarding
that
i wonder if you could just um before i
open it up peter just give us just give
us um
by the way can i say i appreciate the
report there may be little changes i
might recommend but it's not they're not
large are you able to give us a sense of
the the weight the seriousness of the
outstanding items uh are you just
dealing with the 16 open items as normal
course of business although any of those
have a particular weighting or concern
that the committee should be aware of
no these are all um minor changes um to
procedures
that need uh require updating
the uh for example the health service
ones
the alcohol ones one of them is just an
update on the ilt boundary map to go on
to city maps on the council website to
get the definition
as in one side of the street is within
the boundary the other side's with
outside the boundary so it's just
getting that
updated for our site
so they're reasonably minor
updates that we're working through now
brilliant no thank you for that peter
and i just want to remind um committee
members that is part of our role about
being getting insurance over systems and
processes that's actually
here i say the boundary thing is almost
music to my ears this is about keeping
things tidy and i appreciate that the
work you're doing are there any
questions folk would like to raise peter
there aren't what's the timeline on
getting those open items closed
uh we've just create had access to a new
software tool where we're managing
the continuous improvements through um a
promet module so we're uploading all the
uh
audit results
and continuous improvements into the
improvement module of pro map so
this takes time upskilling the team but
going forward we should be able to start
closing these off more regular each
month
and and put it in a and i ask it
carefully um but
you've got the full cooperation of you
know internally of of managers and what
have you with these up these updates the
the the open items
um yes and
with the promet module we'll be able to
assign an owner and they'll get
notifications when they have to review a
process and that going forward
brilliant
right i sense this is a good information
uh matter unless there are any other
questions oh michael you've got a point
please
yes thank you um cheer look i just
wanted to highlight to the councils that
we are and peter just mentioned that we
are looking at trying to bring in a
better tracking system to allow managers
to give comments back and forward in
relation to that so we can bring high
risk items through to this
committee
and
that will have
details and comments straight from the
managers that we'll be able to share
from that purpose so we're working
through that and we're hoping to have
that in draft by the september meeting
but we would be looking to have that
finalised by the december
risk and assurance
thank you that would be helpful i mean i
think if you just take a a small hint
from me uh michael and peter as to where
i'm keen to go i'm keen to see
the movement through and um any
particular weighted or
or indicative matter that's serious
which
is is otherwise impeding just dealing
with something so that's great
before we could move then to the
recommendation please which is that we
note we note and i just received the icc
continuous improvement program update
i'll move that from the chair do i have
a second to
please thank you very much um ross
appreciate that um any discussion on the
motion
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say hi
again
those against it's carried thank you
item 10 is sensitive expenditure
uh
and again another really important
information oneness and the previous one
was
um
so
uh
uh jamie or michael is the any opening
comment you want to make or should we
discuss will i just open it straight up
to uh
being received and opened up for
committee members to make comment on
uh what
yeah okay um
yeah so just take the report as read um
just one thing we'd probably suggest the
committee consider is the recommendation
to gets expanded a wee bit um currently
says notes to expenditure
and i think the committee should
consider changing that to notes
note the expenditure and agree that is
appropriate
oh in the resolution
yes
yes got you i think that's fair enough i
mean that's the whole that's the whole
process here is that it gives us a
chance a chance as a committee as a risk
committee to get to gauge
are we in a way that we think is correct
and sorry that is appropriate so i don't
have any trouble with the suggestion
that we add that to the resolution
so look i open it too many people like
to raise questions about the the
schedule uh about any of the matters
that are that may or may not have caught
your eye there please
i think by the way there's a reasonable
amount of information here and the way
that's developed for me but over the
last couple of meetings which i
appreciate but if the are there any
questions folk would like to raise
right seems like it's pretty clean
that's good can we please go to the
resolutions then um which
we have just added to um and i'll as
cheers
process i'm going to recommend that we
just run with what jamie suggested
so um the recommendation is that we
receive a report on sensitive
expenditure and that we note we know the
expenditure and agree
that it is appropriate which i think is
um as i've said right
okay i'll move that motion please do i
have a second you'll need to shout your
name out
rangy
thank you ringy appreciate that um i'll
uh i presume there is no further
discussion on the motion
all those in favor please say aye
aye aye
thank you those against
it's carried thank you very much
right again another one of those normal
reports that we should get um just to
understand uh broader issues um so
michael the quarterly financial reporter
patricia
or jamie i don't know who it's going to
be but it's always a good surprise
patricia please
hi patricia
sorry i'll introduce it but um jamie um
can equally answer as many any questions
this was presented to the ppp committee
on the 10th of august but has been
brought back here in cases any um to
raise any issues of risk
or any risk issues that need to be um
within this
i'll leave it as read i'll take it as
read but as
um open it up for any questions
thank you patricia jamie
um just a comment on that um this is
just a snapshot of the quarter four um
performance it is not to be taken as a
draft in a report
um we're still working on these numbers
because of the change in finance systems
we're having to
have a bit more detail than digging into
the background just to make sure the
numbers are right so um
the giraffe is currently showing a
operational surface of 4.9 million
um we do expect that to come back to
about um break even
and the capital program was in line with
what we had forecasts during the rtp
process for last year
any questions
thank you jimmy i noticed the good
accountant conservatism and cautions so
well received and i've seen it through
the paper so so well done
um so of folk can i open up for
questions i have a couple but uh i
wonder if colleagues you have some first
just the one bruce
yes knowing um just in relation to uh
recommendation
two that jamie's just talked about that
on on at this point we're showing a
surplus of 4.9 and we may very well come
back to a break even position
two issues within that i guess one when
will we know
um what the true position is at the end
of the year and it is i guess a little
bit concerning that we have a
potentially a five percent variance
in our reporting system that
that needs to be drilled down on um that
we the end of quarter report has
potentially that five percent variance
and that's that's significant on 100
million dollars
okay in terms of when we expect to have
a better number there is another paper
in public excluded regarding the annual
report
this is still subject to audit and it
will be much later this year we're
looking at around november december when
the auditors will actually be in the
building
i would expect that within the next two
within the next four weeks we will have
that as a much much better number
um and we'll be able to give councillors
an update of where we see the draft and
report being at
and um in relation to the councillor um
your question about this is unusual i do
agree it is unusual and um i would
expect going forward that this would
this isn't
that this would not happen again we'd
have a much better number closer to the
year end
thank you
at the risk i haven't read my paper
properly patricia what what
what
zero can you repeat that again
sorry what is what are the what are the
matters that you have got to confirm yet
before you can tell us what the surplus
number is
um we're just going through the year end
accruals making sure that we have got
the timing cut off correct um and um
confirming doubtful debt positions
those are probably the two biggest jamie
was there anything else that i've missed
um yeah there's also the
three water swimmers money and travel
really really money we need to work out
how much of that revenue to recognize
this financial year and how much needs
to be put as the liability on the
balance sheet
right just chipping in the chair sorry
video's not working
um
just wanted to highlight that
probably about 90 percent of that
variance is in relation to those last
two items um and this is an unusual
position from that perspective so
revenue recognition is quite a large
item
got you that's appreciate that um
michael and jamie and patricia that's
great any other questions from folk
thank you for your knobby
just from a um
you've covered off one which is actually
the numbers moving quite substantially
and thank you for explaining why that's
the case
um i did notice and it's not a large
number um but i did notice the lower
employee expenses reflecting a vacancy
and we can we can play numbers and work
out how many staff that might be over
the course of the year
i just wondered whether there was any
impact of not being able to fill our
vacancies
in terms of our service delivery
i wonder if somebody is able to give me
a some advice on that
it's one thing it's one thing to have
money back in the bank because we had a
vacancy factor but we need to spend the
money to be able to do things so are
there things we haven't been able to do
what do we have what's the organization
under stress
i wonder whether rhiannon have you can
you answer that one from what you've
seen to date and collecting the kpi
information
bruce i wonder whether it's more
appropriate for me to respond to that
um
patricia's asked the question in
relation to kpis
i think each of the group managers would
acknowledge that there have been areas
under stress as a result of an inability
to fill vacancies
michael could certainly tell you about
some of the areas in finance and
assurance where he hasn't been able to
make the progress that he might have
liked similarly aaron has had
areas where we've managed but it's been
uh we've been squeaking in rather than
being able to do it with the level of
assurance that we'd really like to
steve's been very fortunate in managing
to recruit
third tier managers into his area but
beneath that i know there are areas for
instance in the museum where there are
some skills that we are currently
lacking
and similarly trudy's area
i think we've been again squeaking in as
opposed to
really being able to meet our kpis
comfortably
okay i think that's something to keep
and a reflection as we as we go through
it clear thank you for that update i
suspect that it was probably across the
organization
um but it does
just as a follow-up to that yep sure
mate um
probably 12 months ago i raised the
issue of
us as councillors not having a a true
handle on salaries
or and uh and the wider costs that sit
within
what it was referred to as personnel
costs which are beyond just salaries of
course
and that's that that one line is 25
percent of our annual operating costs
and and i know uh
i've had some opposition just before but
i i think it would be helpful going
forward to have as part of the corkly
update or even the six months of the
outback just a breakdown of what
claire's just finished telling us so
that we can see where those vacancies
are falling and have some understanding
of how that impacts on service delivery
thank you nobody can i was clear to
consider that i i
i mean i guess i have some sympathy in
one sense
maybe that you can see i am relating the
financial results to actually what does
it mean in terms of performance just as
we do and having the earlier item
between financial performance and
capital delivery
um is actually really important
so thank you cliff that appreciate that
it is a general stress across it and i
guess when we get to the full annual
report and see the kpis
um it'll be interesting to see how
that's how that's affected
but of course there's a risk matter it
also worries me that if as you suggested
there are numbers of parts of the
organization
um um um shall we say struggling to have
a full compliment then raises questions
around health safety and well-being so i
appreciate that
are there any other points people would
like to raise at this point for a for a
paper that you've already seen through
the finance committee any other
questions people like to raise
there being none i wonder if i can just
move to the resolutions then which uh
jamie has outlined is
is just more than just receiving
as we note that firstly given it's the
annual report it is a quarterly update
not the draft annual report
um and that we have year-end accounting
adjustments still to be applied
which will allow the current operating
surplus to towards a break-even
performance and again i just break in
there to reflect michael's going to
strong lead us to where those key
changes are
council has a draft operating surface of
4.9 well with that point above and the
capital program spenders in line was
forecast
i'll put that motion dive a second to
please
thank you darren uh alex
oh i've gotta i got darren's hand up
first i was i was hoping that the chair
of finance or whatever it is strategy
policy wherever you out there and might
have said yes
absolutely
otherwise
are there any are there any um there's
any discussion on the motion
darren has anything you want to say as a
seconder
no
i don't think you might be muted mate
but i think i oh sorry thanks chris
appreciate that
okay so i'll put the motions in all in
favor please say i
it's carried okay we have um
uh we have item sorry item 12 which is
urgent business um i have no
um
indication of urgent business
and if we could move back to the
start of the
motion which talks about
moving into public excluded and i just
said there were a couple of matters i
wanted to raise
um firstly i think it's important that
within this if i've got it right we note
um that we want jeff and lindsey to
remain please
but i've had uh somebody just tied it up
for me that the reasons for public
exclusion
so under um if you go to b please on the
next page
um with the council irrigation update
you'll notice change there the reason is
section 72g to protect legal
professional privilege
and also undersea where we have
the internal audit program update
um that the reason is under both seven 2
a which is to protect the privacy of
natural persons
etc and 7 2 j
which is to prevent the disclosure or
use of information from proper gain or
improper
advantage
so those have been clarified for us so
thank you for that um who's who've done
that management
um uh so look i'd like to move at the
stage that we uh move into
public excluded for the reason stated
and that we also allow
lindsay and jeff to remain i'll put that
motion please do i have a second
yes first
thank you darren all those in favor
please say aye
i was against
it's kerry that's brilliant